buonasera
non vi nascondo che ciò quasi il terrore
a toccarlo questo l'ho visto quello che
è successo i predecessori ma chissà che
invece non riusciamo a trovare la quadra
allora partiamo
partiamo subito cosa succede quando vi
capita di vivere un'emozione talmente
forte e un'esperienza talmente forte da
condizionarvi per il resto della vita
può sembrare anche che magari questa
esperienza agli occhi degli altri sia
una banalità ma in realtà per voi
diventa un qualcosa di estremamente
importante che vi segna per il resto
della vostra esistenza
a tal proposito voglio raccontarvi la
storia di un ragazzo che chiameremo r
per semplicità era in procinto di
passare dalla pubertà all'adolescenza
quindi un momento decisamente importante
per lui
passare da un momento in cui tutto è
incentrato sul io allo scoprire tante
altre cose che lo circondano e in
particolare l'altro sesso e quindi
quello che prima era visto quasi come
per carità improvvisamente diventa è
però ecco ed è quello che è successo
anche ad rr si innamora della sua amica
e siccome timido decide di scrivergli
una lettera per manifestare i suoi
sentimenti
purtroppo non avrà mai risposta quella
lettera r cimarra ci rimarrà veramente
male passa un anno andiamo avanti e era
ricostruita forza la porta del suo cuore
ma l'amore eccolo che toc toc bussa
nuovamente questa volta è una sua
compagna di classe bella mora e decide
questa volta prende coraggio e dice mi
dichiaro e lo fa apertamente stavolta
senza passare per la lettera è la
risposta stavolta arriva però non è
quella che voleva sentirsi dire perché
mi dispiace ti vedo solo come un amico
un classico e la porta del cuore dr
viene sbattuto in malo modo nuovamente
va in mille pezzi
inizia a domandarsi se tante volte non
sia lui che è un problema non sia lui
che non vada bene agli altri e questo
tormento lo accompagna per un po ma
andiamo avanti
arriviamo a un sabato sera sabato sera
quindi tutti i ragazzi vanno in centro o
per la movida the week end e lui è lì
che cammina con i suoi compagni e poi
mentre cammina ripensa un po le sue
esperienze nei momenti in quel momento
passa un autobus e dal finestrino aperto
due ragazze tirano fuori il braccio e
puntandolo dicono sei brutto sei brutto
davanti a tutti il sabato sera riccardo
sprofonda e non sa più come rialzarsi
inizia veramente a dubitare vorrebbe
piangere ma non lo fa scappa a casa e
rimane dentro casa rinchiuso per tutto
il resto della della serata accompagnato
perché non ci vogliamo far del male da
una musica malinconica ma è questo
questo sei brutto queste esperienze
negative vissute rimangono nel nella sua
testa pero ancora tanto tempo anche se
poi ovviamente cresce e inizia a farsi
anche le sue esperienze ma quella
esperienza è lì che lo tormenta e lo
segnalo segna anche nella vita di tutti
i giorni
poi a un certo punto dice ma perché devo
andare avanti così e soprattutto scopre
che il suo problema nei confronti degli
altri
parte dal fatto che per prima cosa è lui
stesso che è lui che ha problemi con se
stesso non gli piace l'immagine che veda
lo specchio ea quel punto decide di
prendere a due mani il coraggio e di
affrontare di petto il problema e quindi
parte e dal curare il suo corpo inizia
dal benessere fisico quindi decide di
mettersi in morto di partire di anche
kula curando un po di più la parte
alimentare
ora mettiamo un attimo in pausa la
storia e veniamo a noi anzi a voi quando
dovete arrivati a un punto tale per cui
le cose che state vivendo nomi vanno più
bene e volete cercare di uscirne magari
tutte le persone che avete a fianco vi
dicono
beh dai ma no ma dai che ce la fai a ma
voi non vi muovete da li dovete prima di
tutto avere il coraggio di guardarmi
allo specchio
dovete prima di tutto avere il coraggio
di ripartire da voi dalla cura del sen
solo in quel momento avrete trovato
veramente il vostro motivo per l'azione
che si tramuterà in motivazione a girare
la pagina ea iniziare un nuovo capitolo
ed è quello che un po è successo a r ora
io non vi sto dicendo di magari di
diventare sportivi professionisti ma vi
sto dicendo semplicemente alzatevi
alzatevi muovete vi fate qualcosa
partite da piccole cose
una passeggiata smetto di fumare
magari aggiungo un po di insalata al
pranzo piuttosto che solo carne qualche
aperitivo in meno ecco piccole cose che
però se piccoli passi fatti con costanza
portano a grandi risultati non è facile
ma se ce la mettiamo
riusciamo a farcelo torniamo ad r r nel
frattempo ha cresciuto e questa
ritrovata autostima lo aiuta moltissimo
nel ritrovare la forza el nel non aver
più paura di guardarsi allo specchio e
chiaro el'autostima da cosa deriva
deriva ovviamente ci aiuta molto dal da
riuscire a trovare la forza di fare le
cose nel caso suo il motivo scatenante è
stata proprio la diciamola
il voler mettere in moto il benessere
fisico ma per ognuno di voi quale può
essere il vostro motivo per l'azione per
poter tornare ad avere un'autostima alta
il consiglio che vi do e cercate di
eccolo qua
riflettete prendete un foglio e scrivete
un in questo foglio la risposta a queste
domande che cos'è che non mi va più bene
nella mia vita
cos'è che sono disposto a cambiare ea
muovermi dallo stato in cui sono adesso
che cos'è che sono disposto a rinunciare
pur di cambiare questo stato
scrivetelo e affigge te questo foglio in
un posto dove potete vederlo tutti i
giorni e tutte le volte che lo vedete
che lo guardate ripetete v se non lo
faccio io
nessun altro lo farà al posto mio
r nel frattempo questa ritrovata
autostima e questa ritrovata forza gli
consentono di avere una maggiore
consapevolezza di sé e una
consapevolezza che si diciamo
che diventa anche una consapevolezza
maggiore delle sue emozioni riesce a
riconoscere le sue emozioni per tempo e
quindi a gestirle cosa che gli permette
di aumentare di migliorare di gran lunga
i rapporti personali
lavora molto di intelligenza emotiva la
consapevo allora le emozioni quando
vengono provate in realtà prima di
arrivare al picco e motivo ci arrivano
dei segnali corporei solo che noi non ci
facciamo caso perché siamo presi dal
arrivare già al punto in cui proveremo
le emozioni sia esse positive che
negative
ma ovviamente l'accento lo voglia oppure
su una persona su quelle negative perché
immaginate quanti conflitti potete
risolvere se riuscite a riconoscere le
vostre emozioni negative prima che esse
si manifestino vedete facile no
non è facile ma potrete allenarvi per
esempio la rabbia a cosa semplice
allora prima di arrivare al picco nella
rabbia all'esplosione il corpo realtà ci
lancia una serie di segnali se ci
pensate per esempio si innalza la
temperatura col pop corporea iniziati ad
avere caldo iniziato a sudare
magari le mani diventano gelide e
iniziate con la gamba perché dice adesso
questo sono tutti segnali che se voi
riuscite a captare prima riuscite a
capire che stati per arrivare
all'esplosione e potrete così
controllarla evitando di arrivarci
pensate quanti conflitti potete
risolvere
da questo punto di vista lo dovete fare
ogni volta che vi accade un emozione sia
anche positiva
non è che deve essere solo negativa
prendete un foglio da puntate v ma
esattamente nel momento dopo in cui
avvenuta le emozioni perché se già
stendete un po di più belle siete già
dimenticati esattamente nel momento dopo
in cui avete provato l'emozione prendete
un foglio appuntatevi le sensazioni
fisiche che avete provato negli istanti
immediatamente prima questo vi
consentira di avere tutta piano piano
allenare la testa a riconoscere le
vostre emozioni
poterne gestire e controllare torniamo
ad r allora r nel frattempo è cresciuto
e oltre al benessere fisico prova
benessere mentale ovvero trova che il
detto mens sana in corpore sano sia
perfetto non è che per prima volta
l'avevano detto così per dire
magari ci aveva un fondo è
effettivamente lo prova su se stesso e
trova più energie studia si impegna
legge cose nuove e questo gli permette
al suo cervello di rigenerarsi
costantemente tramite la neurogenesi ma
che cos'è la neurogenesi allora
immaginate pensate che gli scienziati
fino a qualche tempo fa pensavano che il
nostro cervello arrivata una certa età
non si sarebbe più sviluppato anzi forse
retroattiva invece oggi sappiamo che non
è così un cervello adeguatamente
allenato cresce e si rinfresca
costantemente attraverso proprio la
neurogenesi cioè la generazione di nuovi
neuroni
immaginate al cervello come a una serie
di sentieri ok se vuoi percorrete solo
un sentiero probabilmente quel sentiero
diventa strada ma conoscerete solo
quella strada se invece ogni volta vi
allenate a percorrere un sentiero
diverso avrete un infinità di vie da
percorrere e questo permetterà la vostra
neurogenesi per cui studiate leggete
fatevi una lista degli argomenti che vi
piacerebbe approfondire vicino ad ogni
argomento inserito il titolo di un libro
che tratta per l'argomento
dopodiché prendetevi l'impegno di
leggere almeno un libro al mese
questo vi consentira di provare
benessere mentale e aumentare la vostra
neurogenica riprendiamo r
nel frattempo r a pag
nel frattempo r è cresciuto e quindi
queste competenze che ha acquisito
iniziano a servili anche nel mondo della
nel mondo del lavoro
di conseguenza questo suo saper
riconoscere le emozioni sue in primis i
ii consente di aumentare come abbiamo
detto la comunicazione con gli altri ma
gli consente anche di riconoscere le
emozioni degli altri di mettersi nei
panni degli altri per cui diventa
empatico
ma che cosa significa empatia intanto
non va confusa con simpatia e ovvio
magari anzi forse la simpatia è una
conseguenza dell'empatia
diciamo che essere empatico significa
per prima cosa riconoscere le emozioni
degli altri come dicevo prima significa
mettersi in contatto con gli alti
significa comunicare con gli altri e
quella comunicazione ricordatevi che
parte prima di tutti dall'ascolto siamo
invece presi dal parlarci sopra sempre
costantemente uno sull'altro e non ci
ascoltiamo al massimo sentiamo qualche
parole e spesso le male interpreti anno
per essere per attivare per alcune per
utilizzare un ascolto attivo dovete
invece essere presenti a 100 per cento
essere presente al cento per cento
significa essere presenti con la testa
col cuore con gli occhi e con le
orecchie
dovete ascoltare prima sono in questo
modo migliore rete le vostre capacità
comunicative e per cui la brawn per cui
ogni volta che avete un colloquio sia
esso di lavoro sia con i familiari con
chiunque
appuntatevi alla fine del colloquio
quelle che sono state tre annotazioni
intanto il linguaggio verbale ovvero
qual è l'oggetto del colloquio che di
cosa abbiamo parlato qual è l'argomento
poi notazioni sul tono della voce quindi
sul paraverbale era monotono alzato il
tono in un certo punto per magari
mettere in evidenza determinati aspetti
del del discorso oppure era basso e poi
anche sul non verbale era calmo era
fermo si agitava come oppure sono tutte
cose che vi permettono di essere
presenti al cento per cento nel dialogo
e di migliorare la vostra comunicazione
se vi allenate a fare questo esercizio
qui
poi alla fine vi verrà naturale
ascoltare l'altro vi verrà naturale
entrare in contatto con l'altra persona
riprendiamo r r come dicevamo è ormai
andato al lavoro e gestisce un team di
persone
questo team di persone grazie a queste
capacità acquisite non lo vede come un
capo in realtà lo vede più come un
allenatore in grado di aiutare la
squadra a raggiungere l'obiettivo
sto parlando di leadership ma leadership
naturale
i veri leader sono autentici non sono
costruiti i veri leader sono fonte di
ispirazione non sono fonte di terrore o
peggio di derisione perché quanti di voi
e sfido chi lavora e sa la famigerata
scena davanti alla macchinetta del caffè
dove tutti dicono tutto contro il capo
perché ho detto capo perché
effettivamente se le persone reagiscono
così quella persona non è un leader è un
capo ed è una cosa diversa e purtroppo
siamo pieni di capi in pochi leader
se vuoi ricordati di leader veri intanto
non si nominano leader ma sono nominati
dagli altri sono riconosciuti dagli
altri leader
pensate ai leader carismatici che hanno
segnato l'esistenza mix solo ed
esclusivamente attraverso il loro
comportamento
mi viene in mente grandi piuttosto che
olivetti tanto per dire qualcuno quindi
per allenare la vostra leadership con
qualsiasi gestite ultime attenzione per
gestire intima non significa che dovete
gestire milioni di persone anche la
famiglia un team sportivo una classe
visto che c'era la prof prima no per
esempio
prendetevi il tempo di dedicare un
giorno alla settimana
prendete a turno uno dei vostri
collaboratori chiedeteli veramente
sinceramente come sta
come si sente all'interno del team e
chiedetegli un consiglio per migliorare
il team
appuntatevi e prendetevi l'impegno di
almeno portare a termine uno dei
consigli che vi è stato dato questo
consentirà di aumentare la vostra
autorevolezza e la vostra leadership
siamo arrivati ormai quasi alla fine
quindi r ormai è cresciuto e ha fatto la
sua profonda della sua professione
l'aiuto degli altri e ha capito che gli
ostacoli si possono parlare davanti alla
vita sei brutto ancora e che già è che
una volta che gli si sono parati possa
diventare macini ma che se ci mettiamo
l'impegno e se lottiamo riusciamo a
toglierli ea portarli avanti è diventato
resiliente ma che cosa significa la
resilienza residenza è nella metallurgia
la capacità dei metalli di resistere
agli urti e di non rompersi negli esseri
umani e la capacità dell'uomo di
resistere agli urti della vita e la
capacità di non mollare la capacità di
andare avanti in questo per questo
motivo scrivete quando arrivate fatto
un'attività che non vi riesce prima di
dire mollo basta lascio perdere
cercate di capire il motivo perché non
vi riesce e impegnatevi con il pensiero
positivo
datevi un ulteriore possibilità pensiero
positivo significa mi informo capisco
cerco di arrivare a soluzioni ma non
mollo non mollo e vado avanti
siamo veramente in conclusione ho
parlato veramente tanto allora r alla
fine ha chiuso il cerchio tutti gli
anelli della catena ci sono uniti in una
ruota e proprio perché parliamo di una
ruota la ruota gira ovvero gli anelli
della catena non possono essere
perseguiti eseguite una volta sola ma
devono è diventare una routine una loop
positivo che si autoalimenta solo in
questo modo riuscirete ad uscire dalle
vostre problematiche e migliorerete la
posta vita ultime due cose la prima
ricordatevi che non è non è mai troppo
tardi per cambiare la vostra vita non
c'è un'età per dire adesso basta
cambio cerco di trovare la mia strada
ok ultimissima r son io ho raccontato la
mia esperienza di vita
e siccome ci sono riuscito io sono
sicuro che potete riuscirci ognuno di
voi quindi adesso andate a casa e
iniziate grazie
[Applauso]